bonjour à tous je m'appelle jean je
m'occupe d'investir avec et aux côtés de
l'examiner dans une centaine de start-up
parents et aujourd'hui pour une fois je
vais pas vous parler du fait que j'aie
meilleur job du monde
même si c'est vrai j'ai meilleur job du
monde parce qu'il est facile on finance
des entrepreneurs qui font tous les
efforts et nous on est juste à côté
d'eux mais on les supporte
il est extrêmement plaisant parce qu'on
finance des gens qui a envie de changer
le monde avec plein de bonnes intentions
et en plus il est profitable parce que
même certains entrepreneurs vont échouer
ce qui nous a plus de gratification vous
nous rendre au centuple
et s'ils avaient pas les entrepreneurs
qui échoue et en face en plus on
n'aurait pas ce sentiment plaint de voir
ces entrepreneurs réussir à côté la
difficulté quand on est dans un job
comme celui là un moment donné c'est de
faire tomber le masque
parce que on est tous on recherche de
réalisation et quand on a le meilleur
job du monde comme moi on a un problème
de syndrome de l'imposture ne s'attend
donc de l'imposture c'est vous cherchez
à vous réalisez et à légitimer légitime
et votre place et légitimer sa place ça
passe par quoi ça passe par des phases
où un moment donné vous êtes un peu
perdu par rapport à ce que vous faites
alors je pensais pas qu'aujourd'hui
j'avais partagé avec vous des messages
un peu privé mais ce qui s'est passé à
la fin de l'année dernière les débuts de
cette année c'est que j'ai reçu des
messages de proches de professionnels
avec lesquels je travaille qui m'ont dit
qu'ils me trouvais pas très en forme
un peu triste et un peu bizarre au début
ça vous touche vous posez la question
vous rendez pas compte et en fait fin
décembre je tombais malade pendant
quinze jours et en fait j'ai atteint les
limites d'une charge mentale et physique
qui était simplement qu'à force de faire
des efforts sans se poser la question de
pourquoi je les faisais n'était pas en
train d'essayer de me réaliser
j'étais pas en train d'essayer de
légitimer ma position je la vivais juste
sans me poser de questions et en fait ce
que je me rendais pas compte
et ir j'ai failli annuler ce talk la
veille puisque j'avais toujours pas
compris ça et je vous raconterai après
pourquoi j'ai compris ça enfin ce qui
s'est passé c'est que je me suis rendu
compte qu'il fallait que je passe pas
exactement les mêmes étapes que ceux des
entrepreneurs que je finance et que je
supporte est l'étape la plus importante
par laquelle on passe tous c'est une
étape de solitude l'étape de solitude
est difficile parce qu'elle se compose
de trois choses du vide de l'ignorance
et l'isolément d'isolement c'est quoi
les allemands c'est quand ce que vous
faites en tant qu'entrepreneur est
tellement puissant tellement fort
tellement intense que vous n'avez pas le
courage de l'expliquer d'en parler et
d'expulser toutes les sensations que
vous avez c'est exact
exactement comme tous les sentiments
très forts vous demandez pas à quelqu'un
qui pleure pendant un enterrement ou à
deux amoureux qui s'embrassent sur un
banc ce qu'ils sont en train de
ressentir ils sont en train de le vivre
et c'est exactement même chose pour un
entrepreneur un entrepreneur vie
tellement de choses qu'un mandat il peut
pas expliquer tout ce qui vit et ça
c'est la difficulté de l'isolément de
l'entrepreneur
la deuxième chose difficile c'est le
vide le vide c'est que lorsque vous êtes
entreprenant avec vous commencez vous
n'avez pas de référentiel c'est comme
courir une course et ne pas avoir de
compétiteur c'est comme essayer de se
retrouver dans l'espace et pas à voir
des toiles pour se diriger
eh bien c'est exactement la même chose
vous commencez une étape et
malheureusement vous n'avez pas de
référentiel
la troisième chose qui est difficile
c'est l'ignorance l'ignorance et qu'on
sait pas ce qu'on sait pas et donc on
cherche à s'accrocher à des choses mais
on sait jamais vraiment où on en est et
ce qu'on doit apprendre et ça c'est très
compliqué cette solitude et la
difficulté que cela reflète on pourrait
dire que c'est affreux à vivre mais en
réalité c'est grâce aux tensions que ça
crée qu'on arrive à se dépasser et c'est
ça qui est extraordinaire avec des
entrepreneurs pour le vide
la tension paradoxale au vide donc
comprenez par tension que si on vit
aujourd'hui si on voit ce qui est bien
c'est parce qu'on a le sentiment du mal
si on arrive à goûter des choses
extraordinaires c'est parce qu'on sait
qu'elle ait le goût des choses qui ne
sont pas bonnes
eh bien c'est la même chose pour un
entrepreneur un entrepreneur c'est
quelqu'un qui doit faire preuve
d'humilité et d'ambition
c'est quelqu'un qui doit faire preuve de
compassion avec des gens avec lesquels
il travaille en même temps d'exigence
pour réaliser de grandes choses
c'est quelqu'un qui doit être flexible
pour voir tout ce qui se passe autour de
lui mais en même temps être très
déterminé pour faire des choix auxquels
il va se tenir
eh bien le vide l'ignorance et
l'isolément ont tous des tensions
paradoxale qui leur permettent
finalement pour nous dépasser
donc pour le vide c'est l'impossible
l'impossible c'est quoi c'est tout
simplement que si vous n'avez pas de
référentiel vous n'avez pas de
limitation
si vous n'avez pas l'imitation vous
pouvez faire des choses que les gens
pensaient impossible
vous avez cet adage qui dit ils l'ont
fait parce qu'ils ne savaient pas que
c'était impossible
eh bien c'est exactement ça quand on
parle de l'ignorance c'est le sujet de
la singularité
parce que vous ne savez pas ce que vous
ne savez pas et bien justement vous
allez développer des singularités qui
sont en dehors des règles connues
est-ce que vous pensez que si on avait
appris à tous les artistes à dessiner de
la même manière on aurait des mouvements
différents on aurait des picasso on
aurait de l'art moderne on aurait tout
ça on n'aurait pas tout ça
l'entrepreneur c'est exactement la même
chose certaine si du singularité qui
s'exprime pour faire des choses
exceptionnelles et c'est aussi ça la
beauté d'ignorance et la troisième chose
c'est que l' isolement vous permet de
vous rencontrer en profondeur donc
visuellement c'est probablement le
sentiment le plus difficile parce que ce
qui fait qu'on ait envie c'est
finalement qu on a la reconnaissance des
autres qu'on vit avec eux et qu' ils
nous le rendent
et quand on est tout seul bah on perd un
peu la raison de vivre
mais cet isolement ils nous emmènent
tellement bas au plus profond de nous
qu'on arrive à se poser les questions
profondes sur la raison des choses sur
pourquoi en effet
pareil vous avez cet adage qui dit que
c'est quand on touche le fond qu'on peut
rebondir débat cet isolement nous sert à
ça il serait rentré en profondeur dans
qui on est pour pouvoir nous trouver
et ça c'est essentiel alors une fois
qu'on a parlé de ses difficultés du vide
de l'ignorance de d'isolement une fois
qu'on a vu qu'il y avait des tensions
paradoxal positive à ces difficultés qui
sont la singularité qui sont la
possibilité et la profondeur il faut
quand même se poser la question de
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour vivre ces
difficultés n'y a pas de secret le seul
moyen de vivre c'est de s'entourer
les gens qui vivent le plus longtemps
dans le monde sait ce qu'ils ont une vie
sociale qui est pleinement rempli mais
quand je dis pleinement remplies ça veut
pas dire avec beaucoup de monde autour
d'eux ça veut dire avec des gens avec
lesquels ils ont développé des relations
profondes
si vous voulez combattre le vide
il faut trouver des semblables est
semblable c'est quoi quand vous êtes
entrepreneur c'est les gens qui sont sur
le même secteur au même stade de
développement
c'est des gens avec lesquels vous allez
pouvoir trouver un référentiel pour
déterminer où vous vous situez
lorsque vous êtes dans le cas de
l'ignorance et que vous ne savez pas ce
que vous ne savez pas il faut que vous
trouviez des modèles des modèles c'est
quoi c'est des gens qui sont déjà passés
par l'étape vers laquelle vous vous
dirigez c'est des gens qui ont déjà la
connaissance du futur et qui peuvent la
transmettre pour vous aider à progresser
et enfin l'isolément il faut évidemment
trouver des proches
c'est sa famille ses amis
c'est des gens qui vont vous divertir le
rôle c'est pas vous de demander un
déjeuner de famille comment ça se passe
la start up
comment ça va à la vie c'est de vous
divertir c'est de vous changer les idées
c'est de vous sortir c'est de parler de
choses qui n'ont rien à voir avec le
quotidien
parce que de toute manière ils ne seront
jamais par quoi vous passer et ce par
quoi vous passer c'est pas anodin
et aujourd'hui c'est ça qui est très
important pour moi et c'est ce que j'ai
réalisé hier et c'est pour ça que tu là
aujourd'hui
les entrepreneurs les plus exceptionnels
et tous les entrepreneurs en général
font face à trois difficultés du monde
qui les entoure qui est le rejet le
doute et l'injustice le rejet de ce
qu'ils leur disent non tout le temps un
entrepreneur va aller voir une centaine
d'investisseurs
les trois quarts vont lui dire non si ce
n'est pas 90 où 99% et pourtant ce rejet
il faut juste l'accepter comme un
paramètre et continuer d'avancer malgré
le fait que les gens vous disent non le
doute c'est que les gens croient pas en
vous et plus votre idée singulière plus
que vous faites et unique plus et
différenciés plus c'est fou plus c'est
impossible et moi on croira en vous et
malgré ça malgré le doute de
l'environnement il faut continuer de se
battre
et puis la troisième chose c'est une
injustice l'injustice c'est que vous
avez beau faire la plus belle boîte du
monde faire les meilleurs choix vous
dépassez vous avez des gens plus
agressif plus fort de meilleur pictures
qui sont dans des dents un qui ont
commencé plus tôt ou qui en commet sont
plus tard ont réussi à bâtir des
avantages compétitifs par rapport à vous
qui fait que même si vous donner le
maximum c'est pas sûr que vous allez
gagner et dans mon métier en tant
qu'investisseur mon job pendant des
années ça a été d'aider des
entrepreneurs qui faisait face au rejet
qui faisait face au doute et qui faisait
face à l'injustice à réussir alors moi à
l'école n'était pas très bon j'étais un
peu isolé introverti et à chaque fois
que quelque chose devait être fait ce
que je préférais c'était de faire moi
même je faisais moi-même parce que je
savais qu'elle était le résultat que je
pouvais obtenir quand j'ai été
investisseurs j'ai aimé ce métier
tout simplement parce que c'était moi
vis-à-vis d'un entrepreneur donc j'étais
le seul responsable de l'impact que
j'avais sur lui c'est ce qu'on a fait
avec des bottes comme capitaine train
comme un ennemi qui sont des entreprises
dans lesquelles personne n'a cru au
moment où ils ont cherché à se financer
ou ils ont cherché à se développer
qui non seulement créer des équipes
formidables mais ils ont créé des
produits formidables ils ont créé des
expériences incroyables pour leurs
utilisateurs et au delà de ça ça a été
un succès financier aussi pour tous les
investisseurs qui sont entrés au capital
de ces startups
moi mon métier j'y suis rentré parce que
j'ai réalisé que ces entrepreneurs passe
au rouge et au doute et à l'injustice
avait du mal à vivre et qu'ils avaient
besoin de soutien de cette observation
j'ai été frustré de cette frustration je
me suis battu et puis un jour xavier
niel m'a donné ma chance et donc on a pu
continuer d'accompagner énormément
d'entrepreneurs mais hier je me suis
rendu compte d'une chose dans le taxi
était au téléphone avec phil le
fondateur de dice qui est un moment m'a
dit jean ça y est j'ai compris le
pouvoir du réseau et je lui dis mais je
comprends pas qu est ce que tu veux dire
par le pouvoir du réseau il me dit mais
c'est ce que tu m'as dit à un an quand
on s'est rencontrés jeudi à bon maire
rappelle moi il ya un an un garçon qui
s'appelle tony fadell qui est un bon
copain de xavier nous a présenté fine
que j'ai rencontrés que j'ai adoré qu'il
fondateur de cette start-up s'appelle
dice point fm
suite à ça on l'a financé puis j'ai
présenté emmanuel qui est un garçon
extra qui est un autre investisseur et
puis jerry et puis antoine et puis
adrien et des gens qui sont devenus
instrumental dans la manière entier à
développer sa boîte est en fait les
effets composée de tous ces gens autour
de lui font qu'aujourd'hui dans une
position exceptionnelle pour réussir et
ça il ne l'a réalisé et moi-même je n'ai
réalisé qu'après que ce se soit passé
dans la matinée
je suis allé voir mathilde à la nouvelle
recrue d'une de nos boîtes qui s'appelle
side et après j'ai discuté avec pierre
le sillon et pendant notre discussion
pierre me dit tu sais des gens comme
adrien comme matilda et d'autre il nous
en faut plus il nous en faut plus autour
de nous parce qu'on a besoin d'eux pour
nous dépasser
ils ont besoin d'eux pour faire face à
toute la problématique que j'ai énoncé
avant du vide de l'ignorance et
d'isolement mais aussi pour faire un
groupe
ensemble pour faire face à ce rejet au
doute et à l'injustice parce que 1
supporters d'une personne ça ne suffit
pas il faut que ce supporters ils soient
pas le moteur du changement il faut que
ce supporters ils soient le moteur pour
motiver d'autres personnes pour
rejoindre l'aventuré est donc ce que
j'ai réalisé hier est ce que vous devez
réaliser aujourd'hui c'est que votre
impact individuel n'a de valeur que si
vous arrivez à fédérer autour de vous
d'autres gens dont les effets composé de
leur action pour permettre de
transformer la vie de ceux qui comptent
pour vous merci
[Applaudissements]